it's called the stanford prison
experiment because it was it was done it
was run by
psychologists at stanford university and
they actually got a whole bunch of i
can't remember the number
like 24 or thereabouts uh volunteers
from the public
no no like past and like incarceration
or
experience in that morning in the police
force or anything like that
but they they just randomly assigned
they're like okay you suppose i was 24.
you 12 are prison guards and you 12 are
the prisoners and we want you to
uh you might have heard of this maybe
not the name
um you don't and here's why
they just said okay you guys are prison
guards you're the prisoners this is a
prison
okay just you know and i think they they
ran it for a certain number of days
they were meant to run it for something
like four or five weeks i can't remember
the exact date but they had
you know they wanted to see the effects
the social effects on
people who they're not actually
prisoners and they're not actually
prison guards and they just said okay
you guys run it
and um yeah it went it went nasty like
there was
physical abuse there was um real
psychological damage done they had to
cut the experiment short because
people were like i can't do this anymore
i gotta leave um
and it was just astonishing that it was
simply assigning a role
and treating people like they were you
know whatever the label
they randomly assigned and um what you
what we got out of it i mean
a lot of things but if you treat someone
like something
they they gradually actually become like
that if you if you say that if you treat
someone as someone who um has no rights
and is in the wrong and i have absolute
power over you
it does something really profound to the
relationship and also what the person
is lying and people said you know years
later that
it was an emotionally scarring event
anyway the point of me saying it
is you know as a teacher right if i
treat you guys yes see there's a point
if i treat you guys as like people who
have no responsibility for yourselves
like okay you've got to hold your hand
through everything then you sort of
become like that which is a bit
sad um it's why i try not to like you
know even if you're not
working well i try not to move you guys
around because i think that's an insult
to you guys
you ought to be able to work well
wherever you're seated
does that make sense you guys are old
enough to do that